can i help you hey sorry to bother you i
i've been hiking all day and i saw you
had a hose out here and i was wondering
if i could fill up my water bottle i
have a hose
yeah
bottom of the stairs go for me
uh i actually i have filtered water in
the kitchen oh i kind of had my heart
set on dirty hose water but if you
insist
[Music]
should i
i'm sorry what
should i wipe my feet i i don't want to
track beach sand into your
oh no that's that's not sand that's the
remains of the guy who used to live here
you know may i'll just use the hose
no it's not like that he gets spilled
all the time at this point he's mostly
lint i'm walden
uh vivian that's a beautiful name thank
you my parents got it from that 70s show
what was it called mod ah yeah
wow this is this is quite a place
your desk is backwards
excuse me well you have this beautiful
view of the ocean and yet your desk is
facing the wall with a picture of the
ocean on it
yeah
actually it's it's the atlantic
it's an inside joke
for myself
uh you know what i'd better fill up and
get going but it's like it's really
starting to come down out there
that's just a little water it's not
gonna melt it's not like i'm the wicked
witch of the west
i mean you can wait it out here if you
want we gotta dinner together i'll order
delivery
really
wow uh yeah that'd be great great okay
oh thank you
you know i gotta ask do you always
invite strangers into your home oh no
usually they invite themselves
so what's your deal walden
good lucky guy
rich
malibu beach house
i bet you only date hot actresses
god no
i never did an actress
they're all crazy
i'm sure they're not all crazy
trust me they are
get this whole fascination with
celebrities anyway i mean
who cares who's dating whom or who's
engaged to who or who has a sex tape
that no one will ever ever see
i know but i have to say i am a sucker
for anything having to do with
brangelina or kimye yeah i have no idea
what that means i thought we were eating
kim yay
you been hiding under a rock for the
last three years no but i have climbed a
few i was a sherpa nepal
yeah and i i drove cattle in argentina
and i uh oh i used to give safari tours
in africa and once i was an assistant
manager at a hot dog on a stick in
pittsburgh
i love hot dogs
i've never even thought about doing
stuff like that i mean although i did
once sit in the splash section at sea
world without a poncho
well then you'd be perfect for my next
adventure crewing on a sailboat to
polynesia
wow
a sailboat to polynesia
[Music]
so what island do you want to hit first
as long as we're together it doesn't
matter
[Music]
that was a close one
i barely caught you guys
i'm still living with you right
[Applause]
[Music]
walden
huh
which one do you want
right now i want both
out here
oh
a new love awaits you
wow
mine says try gluten-free wontons
[Music]
men